欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
这一小节我们来讲一下怎么样去做一个有营销属性的详情页
让客户看到了发学们的概率更大
因为很多时候我们做详情页的时候大多数人都是自娱自乐
没有基于买家的需求和没有根据买家的一个想要看到的东西去呈现
所以就会导致很多产品详情页只有点击访客
却没有询盘,大概率也是因为它的内容布局的不够好
或者内容没有足够的吸引客户, 所以才导致它的询盘转化率低
那么产品详言业排版的结构通常包含哪些内容呢
包含以下八个内容, 但是呢这些内容不是唯一的, 也就是你这些内容中你可以去挑选一些内容去展示
并不一定都要全部展示, 而且它的顺序
你不一定按照这个顺序, 你可以按照
你们这个行业客户最想看到的内容的重要程度进行一个布局
首先第一个就是产品详情页的顶部可以设置折扣券或者是微卷
第二个就是产品的参数表格等等数据的展示
第三个就是产品的一些细节展示
第四个就是关联销售产品的矩阵
产品的矩阵也就是导购
产品的导购也就是进行二次引流的产品的一些新领的款式或者是报款引流
第五个就是产品的包装样式物流这些定制能力呈现出来
第六个就是产品的生产流程图
场景展示出来也就是你工厂的一些流水线啊
这些都要展示出来
第七个就是工厂实力展示
还有公司的一些销售啊
其他的团队的各种证书啊
这些都要展示出来
末尾的话如果我们没有采用第三方的强盈页设计的话
那么我们是没有办法做到跳转到首页的
如果能做到跳转到首页就是最好的
因为客户浏览你的一个产品强盈页
如果他一直滑到最底部的之后
如果我们底部有引导他发行盘
或者是有引导他返回
那么这个客户可能就会多一个动作
那么在做这些详情页的前提准备
要怎么样去准备呢
第一个就是收集一些高转化的同行产品的详情页去参考
第二个就是我们要把这些核心的内容
还有这些案例给到美工
让他去参考去设计
第三个就是详情页面版本
一定要裁剪成短的图片
再上传到后台
因为我看到有些商家
他们做了一个详情页一整页下来
美工做了一整页详情页
那么他是一张大的图片
很多人他就直接把这张大的图片
直接上传到后台了
那么这么大的图片
在客户点开详情页的时候
就会很卡住的时候
客户就没有耐心
直接把这个详情页关掉了
就会导致你的
产品的详情页
只有点击没有访客
因为点了
但是没有看到你的详情页加载完成
第四个就是
我们要学会保存
详情页的模板和通用模板的应用
来提高我们的工作效率
就像我刚才讲的
你要做一个
模板详情页放在那里
你只要一点这个模板详情页出来之后
我们就可以对这个模板进行
部分的更改
这样的话能够提高你的工作效率
另外一个就是通用模板的应用
比如说公司的介绍
或者是其他板块
所有的产品都用了模块
那么你就把它
弄一两个
或者是一到三个出来进行一个测试
看哪个转化好
就留下哪个就可以了
第五个就是
要制作详情页导航
这个的话我们现在也可以不做了
因为
后台它更新为最新的模板的话
暂时没有显示这个出来
第六个就是我们要学会批量投放工具
用于爆品的持续营销
也就是在产品详情页中
我们要使用
批量投放工具
第七要学会测试
详情页的模板
比如说同一款产品
可能会有
三个到四个链接
那么你就要让这三到四个链接的点击量
差不多的时候
你用不同的详情页匹配
这几款产品
那么你就能够知道
哪些产品的详情页转化比较好了
那么第八个就是优化优爆品
这个产品详情页的时候一定要
记得保留原始的模板
因为你在优化爆品的时候很有可能就是
用到了一个更差的模板
所以你要把原来的模板先保留
如果你测试这个模板太差了
那么你还可以更换为
原来的
模板
具体我们来后台看一下
怎么去操作
刚才讲到的一个就是
我们要去找到同行的一个优质的
产品详情页
首先我们可以从榜单这里看
随便点一个榜单
点进去之后
我们来看
销售最
大的那些详情页
你要去找
那些款式跟你极为相似的那些产品
公司的主营类目跟你操
极为相似的品类的那些你进去看
看这些看什么呢
首先我们看他的至少要是有
成交的有成交有评价的而且是很高的而且是这些是很高的有这些条件之后再去看那个响明页才有
价格
我们来看一下他的具体展示的内容
我们要看什么呢
首先第一个
就是要看他们展示的内容
是什么
他们用的是哪些
描述
以及他们的结构是怎么样的
也就是他的排版先到什么再到什么你要去
这样去看
做一些定的归类起来
你看这些
先去看他先
呈现什么
再到什么模块再到什么模块
以及他呈现的内容是什么
哪些是客户比较
偏好的而且关注的
你就要去重点展示客户
在意的点
以及你能够帮助客户解决的那些
麻烦
那么你就
能够更好的去吸引
客户
因为客户来
买东西或者是
找产品
你的产品一定是他想要的同时呢你能够
给他提供他想要的服务
或者是能够帮他解决他当下的一个焦虑或困惑点
这些都是
有利于提升我们的循环转化
这些都要去看
另一种方式呢我们要在这里搜索
比如说我们搜索一个核心词
搜了一个核心词之后
那之后我们这些是广告位是吧你看这些是广告位
这广告位我们跳过广告位那么我们从
没有广告位
点进去看
看自然排名的大概
前10个
前10个产品或者是你想看更多前20产品都可以
你看
这些
都可以点进去看
一个点进去看要首先一定要确保你看这个
的成交量
一个数据
再往下看
他呈现的内容是什么
以及你可以看一下客户的评论
客户都在意的是什么你要去看客户在意的是什么
那么你就呈现什么内容给客户就可以了
客户关注的点
他越能够得到
解决
那么这些
问题那么就能够
更容易吸引客户
你看这样去看
就可以了
这个都是一样的思路
按照这个思路去看就可以了
我们来看一下
营销这里
场景搭配在APP段的话我们也要学会
怎么样
让产品组合起来
卖给别人
那么就用这个场景搭配
就可以了
那么这个就是我们
去做详解业的时候要考虑的
问题
以及我们要怎么样去参考
做出一个
更适合我们的
详解业
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们来讲一下关于万户首页怎么样去做